Hello Freak bitches.
You know,
that's another one of the things I tried
to think through is why you should tell
the truth. So it's not self evident,
man. A smart kid. The smarter the kid,
the earlier they learn to lie.
Lying is very powerful because you can
manipulate the world with your language
and then you can get what you want lots
of times or escape from things that you
don't want. So why not
lie all the time? Well,
I think the reason is
there's a bunch of reasons,
but one of the MS is that you
can't trust yourself if you lie.
And there's going to be times in your
life where you have no one to turn to
accept you. And so if you've
stuffed yourself full of lies,
then you're going to be in a crisis one
day and you're going to have to make a
decision and you're going to decide wrong
and you're going to be in real trouble
because he won't have the clarity of mind
necessary to make the proper judgment
because you've filled your imagination
and your perception with with rubbish.
So,
and if you really think that through,
you see there's this old idea in the
old testament that fear of God is the
beginning of wisdom.
And I kind of understand what that means
because one of the things say we do
with the future authoring program, we
offer people a little heaven. It's like,
okay,
construct your ideal,
a mad it come up with a plan. You
get to modify the plan, no problem.
You're going to do a bad job of
it, no problem. Just do it. Okay,
so then now you've got a goal and
now you're approached systems.
Technically speaking,
the positive emotion systems that
motivate you are you are engaged because
they're engaged in relationship to a
goal and the more transcendent the goal,
the more they're engaged.
But that's not good enough.
It's great to run towards
something you like,
but it's even better to run away
from something that terrifies you.
So then we ask people, okay, so here,
think about this real carefully.
Take all your faults and your inadequacies
and your, your hatred for life,
all of that.
And then imagine that gets the upper hand.
And then think about where you could
be in three to five years and everyone
knows, hey, some people know
they'd be a street person,
some people know they'd be an alcoholic,
some people know they'd be a
prostitute or a drug addict.
Like everybody's got their own little
hell they could descend into with fair
degree of rapidity and a fair bit
of enjoyment and people know that.
And so I say, well,
delineate that out too.
So you know where you're headed
when you fall off the path.
And so then you're running away
and running towards like, yes,
well heaven and hell and you need it.
And they're real.
They're as real as anything that you can.
It depends on what you
mean by real I suppose, but
there's real as you make them.
How about that?
And people can make hell pretty real.
People do seem to construct
these pitfalls for themselves.
I mean self sabotage is one of the most
common things that you find in people
that are struggling.
I mean,
you would think that
someone who is struggling,
the last thing they'd want to do is help
themselves towards their own demise.
But it's super common. You have, well,
I've thought about that too. And so you,
you tell me what you think this as. If
you talked to people, they say, well,
I want to have a meaningful
life. Generally people want
that. But then you think,
well then what? Why aren't
you? And then you think, well,
what does it mean to have a meaningful
life? Exactly. And then you think, well,
maybe it means that you have to take
on responsibility cause you, your,
your sacrifices have to
be worth something, right?
It has to have some cows to have
some meat. What you're aiming at.
It has to be something that can elevate
your worm-like self to the level of
tolerability. You know, you can say,
well yeah, I've got all these flaws,
but look at what I'm trying to do. Right?
That's the real ground of self respect.
Well,
okay.
[inaudible].